we're going to begin with the hope but
also dwindling window of opportunity as
search Crews try to find five people on
board a submersible that disappeared on
its way to the wreck of the Titanic in
the Atlantic a Canadian aircraft
reported underwater banging noises that
continued at regular intervals from
Tuesday into Wednesday however there are
now fears that oxygen in this vessel may
have already run out the search area has
also expanded it's gone from Big to
really big double the size of
Connecticut at this point and Roxanna
severi is in Boston for us once again
following all of it Roxanna good morning
Good morning Tony the submersible had an
estimated 96 hours worth of oxygen which
is expected to run out this morning if
it hasn't already Rescuers have turned
their focus to a remote area of the
North Atlantic where underwater banging
noises were detected the Coast Guard
says they don't know the source of those
noises but a Canadian airplane aiding in
the search detected them every 30
minutes
we're searching where the noises are and
that's all we can do at this point after
two days of detecting noises underwater
the Coast Guard said Wednesday there's
still hope for the five people on board
ocean Gates missing submersible this is
a search and rescue mission 100 but both
time and oxygen are running out in any
search or rescue case you look at all
the different factors how long we've
been searching what the probability is
the oxygen on board there is more than
just one piece and right now we're
focusing on the search more rescue
vessels are joining the effort but
searching for the small Titan in the
near freezing and Pitch Black conditions
on the ocean floor is challenging if I
were a family member I would remain
helpful
but
people generally do not come back from
the bottom of the ocean Captain David
Marquez was the naval commander of the
submarine USS Santa Fe do you find it
odd that there is no method of
communication that the passengers could
have had no I find it ominous I find
that it's a signal that Crews
incapacitated I don't think they had a
pinger or anything though they were just
communicating by text message yeah it's
a commercial organization they're trying
to be really Innovative and Cutting Edge
on our submarines we would have more
devices but we have a nuclear submarine
that costs two billion dollars so we
have the luxury of having all those kind
of things Ocean Gate has faced criticism
for years this company decided to sell
certify engineer Bart Kemper was part of
a marine Technology Group that expressed
concerns in 2018. follows no code and
follows no jurisdiction Kemper said the
company agreed to be more transparent
with passengers but continued to operate
as an experimental vessel without what
the group said is typical certification
how rare is it for something like this
to happen we have not lost a
non-military submersible before we've
had failures we've had fatalities but
we've never had this type of incident
happened before
more search vehicles have been joining
the effort including a French deep
diving robot that could help release a
trapped vessel but even if teams do find
and free the Titan Before Time runs out
it would still be a challenge to bring
it to the surface Gail
it's just so agonizing the more you hear
the worse it sounds but I still think
you got to have hope thank you very much
Roxanna thanks